[Musique]
écoute attentivement
regarde
apprendre
mortal kombat a commencé
il y a une guerre à
venir que nous devons combattre avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard
[musique]
mortal kombat dans les théâtres et sur hbo max
le même jour exactement noté r
une invitation
signifie que vous avez été choisi pour quel
mortal kombat
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas beaucoup de temps
bien s'ils veulent se battre
donnons-leur un
combat mortel qui est le premier de l'
histoire différentes cultures font
référence à un grand tournoi
mortal kombat
noms jax sonia luke  kung last school
[Musique]
je suis
[Musique
] tout est vrai
un dragon marquant
c'est une invitation
signifie que vous avez été choisi pour quel
mortal kombat
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas beaucoup de temps
bien s'ils veulent se battre
donnons leur de l'argent
[Musique]
mortal kombat qui est le premier
dans les salles sur hbo max le 16 avril classé r
vous